let's talk about bisexuality it is the
hottest of all the sexualities these
days and there was an article in The New
York Times last week where they were
talking about coming out as bisexual at
work and why that is difficult and I got
a quote here I just want to read this is
one of the ladies talking about coming
out of her office she said it never
seems appropriate to say the word sexual
in a work environment and it's simply
awkward if I came out to a straight man
for example he would seem to take it in
a sexual way coming out to women I just
get scared that they were that they will
be uncomfortable or think I'm coming on
to them also it gets really were D which
is the tough part I guess for bisexuals
and we have a noted bisexual here at
this table Bree you are by side I
whispered it to you before even yeah
here's the thing I hate the word you
represent all bisexuals now so okay well
I my I feel like my case is very
different and I feel like I relate more
to pansexual people but I for me
personally it's not about liking guys or
girls it's about liking whoever I fall
in love with okay so how is that
different for the layman how's that
how's bisexual different than pancetta
because I wouldn't well pansexual is you
like everyone I I don't really know the
exact definition of pansexual I've heard
so many different things about that and
I I just don't like to be I feel like
bisexuality has such a stigma and it's
just not fair like people don't take it
seriously so I hate using the word I
just if I am attracted to a woman I'll
say I'm attracted to this woman you know
what I mean it's just it's hard
especially in the workplace
it really depends on where you work I
think that it's safe to say anything at
all does that seem legit to you like
there's this idea that if you're
bisexual it's like oh you're just so
horny all the time you're just doing
with anyone anywhere that is a stigma
right obviously a fairly accurate one
yeah yeah it's just not fair honestly
yeah fair no I think I think the thing
is this article you know it's like when
she said that I feel like if I talk say
the word bisexual to a man then he'll
think that you know I'm hitting on him
and the same thing and I think the
response honestly the way I feel yeah
you're probably right because you
probably should if they're not your
friends at work and they don't get where
you're coming from you probably
shouldn't be talking about sex right
that what is it why would you be you or
you probably are hitting on them or you
know it's like why are you bring it's
not like oh yeah oatmeal for breakfast
and I had sex with a woman last night
Yeah right but is it a bit of a problem
with that that then only a gay person or
a bisexual person would have to deal
with that kind of straight person you
come into work in the morning and talk
to a stranger about like you know
meeting a hot guy laughs I mean you know
it's just not appropriate there's
certain things until you've developed
that kind of safe zone and Trust with
someone and they're considered your
friend and you would have that
conversation you know at a coffee shop
at a bar it's like keep business
business exactly you don't code you
don't go into work talking about how
straight you are all the time exactly
you know the thing is then you get into
the whole sexual harassment thing
because those same women or men you know
will be the first to be filed some
sexual harassment rightfully so if
something were to happen but it's like
you're opening up that that sector and I
think it's just not a protects it I'm
actually surprised to hear you say that
cuz it seems to me that a woman let's
say a woman was a lesbian and she goes
to work and at the watercooler in the
morning there's someone that she so
happens to work with and they said well
what'd you do last night and she said I
went on a date with a girl so you think
that no that's appropriate that's
appropriate cuz I went on a date I'm
dating this woman you don't have to be
like oh not the broader yeah you don't
have to say I went on a date with a girl
last night cuz you're like that's
besides the point if you want to have
sexuality accepted in this country you
have to remove that kind of like I went
on a date and it was with a woman yeah
you know it's a no I happen to go on a
date or I'm dating someone she's awesome
yeah all right well I want to keep
focusing on bisexuality here for a
second because there is an idea at least
with with gays and maybe more with gay
men that bisexuality does not exist so
you are a lesbian look at this we got
gay guy bisexual chicken always be on a
panel think this is the first time in
the history of anything do you believe
in
bisexuality and I say that with green
yeah yeah absolutely you know and when
she was saying
pansexual I think I think for me the
term pansexual kind of embodies like
genderqueer you know like however you
identify his gender and sexuality are
two different things you know so I think
pansexual bisexual might be like I am
attracted to both men and women
pansexual at least in my eyes is more
like you know it doesn't matter if you
your gender in your sexuality match like
I'm going to fall in love with you as a
person yeah do you think when you've
told people that you're bi do you think
guys somehow get off on it more like
there's you know like if a girl says
she's a lesbian well the guy's like
alright I'm out nothing I can do but
somehow they're gonna end up with you
and five other chicks because that's how
it works right this may be getting
personal I've had mixed responses but I
know from people that I've been in a
room in relationships with it's scary
it's a scary thing to them and it's it's
a threatening thing because now there's
double the competition which is that
Woody Allen joke or whatever I don't
know the whatever that joke was but um
yeah I mean it depends it really depends
some guy I mean it depends on what type
of guy you're talking to yeah a lot of
guys are very mature believe it or not
and they are very mature
yeah and they don't then they say okay
and they are you know accepting yeah
what do you guys think about guys when
it comes to bisexuality because deaf I
mean you hear this all the time like a
girl in college can make out with a girl
and nobody thinks anything of it but you
never hear of like through straight guys
me I mean if a guy makes other nothing I
hear about it doesn't happen yeah I mean
we see this stems back to just general
acceptance and gender roles in society
and like we live in a still patriarchal
society where like it's okay for women
you know it's still that it has sexual
association where it's like hot and safe
it doesn't kind of challenge the male
heteronormative kind of structure
whereas like I'm sure most guys or a lot
of guys I don't know but I'm not one but
maybe you can answer this better have
you at least made out or maybe like a
circle jerk I don't know what what's
your twice but that
yeah this is [ __ ] very we got to move on
okay let's uh